Jordan is with us in North Carolina hi
Jordan Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
babe how are you better than I deserve
what's up in your world thank you so
much for taking my call so I've got a
little bit of an issue I have been a
Dave Ramsey fan my whole life and I've
had no debt and then I'm married into
debt and I'm getting ready to inherit
around 1/2 million dollars about how
much within the next one to two one to
two million dollars yes sir I hate it
when that happens
the problem is I see the weight of the
responsibility money for our family yeah
my husband too does the lottery okay
then you've got some danger signs in
your marriage and you've got some work
to do there right exactly does your
review of it is more accurate it is it
is a it is not the lottery it is a
responsibility exactly and so I don't
know what to do because he's just like
we don't have to you know pay for food
anymore because we'll have that money
but it's like I don't want my dad's
inheritance to be paying for me to eat
yeah you guys are like the provider yeah
maybe you oughta like work yeah does he
have a job
he does right now he's driving uber and
he's a real estate agent but he's not
really into it and so that's kind of the
reason he sees it as the lottery and I'm
seeing it as if you jus eight yeah well
let me tell you what money does it
magnifies the good in people and the bad
in people and if your husband is not
motivated and is not a hard worker money
will expand those negative
characteristics and it sounds like
there's a little bit of that no no
sounds like there's a little bit that
going over and I'm gonna address that
head-on with him no we are not using
this money so we can sit on our butt we
are using this money so that you can go
be somebody and you're gonna work your
butt off and no you're not gonna quit
driving uber and know you're not going
to quit doing real estate or more
yeah unless if you do quite um you're
gonna do something else we are not going
to touch this money to live we're not
going to touch it to live because you
guys have got to have the dignity of the
ability to earn for your own family
right and that this is what we call
trust fund baby syndrome right mm-hm
people become useless and don't have the
dignity of having produced and created
anything because they sit and live off
of the interest of Daddy's money and
that is not what we want that's not what
you want that's not what I want and
we're not going to allow a situation for
that to occur for your husband how old
is your husband my husband is 26 and I'm
30 okay all right well I think we get
you know him with some guys around him
and get some career coaching for him and
let's let's figure out what he wants to
be and let's get about the business of
being that and just explain to him this
money is not for you to be lazy this
money is for you know it is for our
long-term use and we're not going to
touch any of it to live we're not using
any of it for monthly budgeting okay and
if you can't do that then you need
marriage counseling don't you exactly
yeah
and so yeah it's um because I just the
problem is I want the money to be a
blessing to your husband
and a blessing is not where he loses his
dignity and his ability and his desire
to produce things in this world and
serve his family that's where happiness
comes from it doesn't come from sitting
on your butt watching Oprah reruns
living off your father-in-law's
inheritance it's just not there's no
happiness in that at all your happiness
comes from creating and producing and
serving and that's where dignity comes
from that's the best life and I want
that life for your husband
so that's that and I'm gonna put create
a situation if I'm you that causes that
to occur for both of you because that's
how you end up with the best marriage
it's how you end up with the best kids
it's how things are going to turn out in
your story the best so let's cause those
variables to happen